somewhere in america today
tucker carlson
is alone
hiding under his desk
in the fetal position sucking his thumb
crying for relief
crying out to his creator that uh things
aren't good because the census report
just dropped there's been a stark
decline in the population of white
people in america and that is go that is
something uh that is going to send him
him and his white supremacist cohort
into a tizzy
reading from the new york times this
this article a rise in hispanic and
asian population fuels u.s growth census
reports
the united states grew significantly
more diverse over the past decade as the
populations of people who identify as
hispanic and asian surged and the number
of people who say they were more than
one race increased the census bureau
reported thursday
overall population growth slowed
dramatically over the past decade
the growth that did occur an increase of
about 23 million people was made up
entirely of people who identified
themselves as hispanic asian black and
more than one race according to these
data
the first racial and ethnic breakdown
from the 2020 census
the white population here we go are you
listening tucker carlson with your great
replacement theory and your your your
your dog whistles to white genocide
which is a racist conspiracy theory that
white genocide is happening through low
birth rates and the promotion of higher
birth rates with people of color
real reasonable
the white population the united states
for the first time on record declined
over the course of the decade people who
identify themselves as white on the
census form have been decreasing as a
share of the country's population since
the 1960s when the united states opened
up more widely to immigrants outside of
europe that drop was driven in part by
the aging of the white population and a
sharp drop in the birth rate again
this
was expected i mean some of these these
dips or the increases in in the the rate
of population of like asians for
instance was surprising
but uh
this has been long foretold in white
supremacist circles as something to be
fearing
that diversity is our weakness tucker
carlson famously said that immigrants
make our country poorer and dirtier
and laura ingram has long whined
about the changing demographics in our
country that nobody voted for
no white people are asking for this
this is good news
diversity is a strength
racial diversity diversity of thought
it is our strength when people have
different lived experiences and they all
work together
drawing upon the the disparate lived
experiences of each other
good things happen
evidenced by the
our country the progress we've made over
the course of the last 50 60 70 years
when things were not good
in america